sono trascorsi 84 bella tutti ragazzi è
bella a tutti i ragazzi siamo ritornati
sull'iter lino dopo 65 mila anni citando
ros divertita ni ricordarmi le tappe
proclami tutto anche solo come si gioca
però voglio vedere madonna live con
questo gioco ci ho condiviso un sacco di
bei momenti anche un sacco di rabbia
effettivamente però perché questa volta
di condividere momenti belli la mia
tattica per chi non avesse mai visto un
mio video di slitte rio è questo e come
non aver visto mio video di epico e
particolare la mia tattica con è sempre
consistita consistita nello stare vicino
a un gigante in modo tale che pena sisti
appena schioppa i fatti tutti i punti
c'è questo si è piazzata la mia tattica
main molte volte anche in video ha
funzionato quindi porco alle varie
quindi a meno che non mi schianto io
eccolo va rivolta perfetto buonissimo
perfetto lo sa cosa mi fortissima e
vabbè la madonna fa dalla strage vi
kinsey of thieves praticamente
bravissimo sono stato bravo
guarda che casino fatto la tattica di
star vicino a quelli più grossi
anche oggi funziona il secondo si chiama
sbucci ecco stare vicino a quelli grossi
va bene se 6 piccolo 6 grosso e rischi
pure te pezzo di culo ecco infatti con
il demonio
voglio provare a chiudere quello verde
mai libici sono andato abbastanza grosso
voglia diventare abbastanza grande da
entrare in classifica teoricamente
questo sarebbe il mio tentativo non è
male puoi provare un affare una sterzata
incredibile attenzione ci ho provato
volo provare a buttare giù il verde
voglio entrare almeno in classifica
adesso siamo 70 esimi ragazzi per entra
in classifica deve stare tra i primi
dieci la vedete a destra è sempre
abbastanza complicato entrare anche solo
in classifica
prima lo sono stato poche volte ma è
successo nei video vecchi sei andato a
cercare attenzione attenzione attenzione
come buono quello verde lo vedo male
perché lo vedo troppo convinto una volta
ero piccolo come questo ho fatto fuori
il primo è stato un momento epocale ho
chiamato anche mia mamma
e stata ottima questa cosa che il casinò
dove fatto rischiato qualcosa rischiando
ecco lo sapevo è perché non riusciva non
riuscirà a dare nessuna parte forse
dovevo mollare il tasto per andare in
sprint però niente male no
ma dai ma dai quanto ha rischiato quistu
quanto rischiato questo stesso amore
questo amore perché si accaparra i punti
guardano e muore muore qualche muore
qualche muore
ora che muore non me lo sento ora che
muore non è morto
sono morto io parto da del bacino con le
morto ehi ehi whatsapp chi è questo
qualcuno lo faccia fuori qualcuno faccia
fuori con lo faccio lo faccio fuori
qualcuno lo faccia fuori o faccio fuori
lo faccia fuori lo seguo
mifi lo so che morirà so che morirà
adesso porca vacca ha rischiato però è
testa di culo hai rischiato contro di me
è preparati perché arrivò a madoff è
morto ucciso è praticamente io perché
l'ho fatto sterzare su un altro
qua devo stare attento che nessuno è
esatto questa cosa qua che è successo
adesso madonna che rischio ok 3000 punti
3 mila punti non c'era arrivato mai
neanche prima a posto allora semi
morisse anche questo davanti
che goduria alla 3000 punti devo
regalato mia devo fare tipo tre volte
quello che ho fatto adesso senza morire
il che non è molto semplice
poi c'è un casi ecco esatto sto dicendo
c'è un casino quindi occhio perché
muoiono tutti infatti stanno ponendo
tutti su di me è fantastico ha fatto un
bordello di punti raga quanto siamo 5
mila punti
non male non male normale siamo a 5 mila
porca vacca
a furia di resistere forse sono
trentesima adesso devo arrivare devo
fare è tantissimo però devo farne almeno
almeno quasi tremila in più però intanto
che o chiusi no
madonna che rischio keys che mi sta
facendo fuori questo perfetto 5200 dai
non male ragazzi sono abbastanza grosso
da far danni cioè mi hanno guardato mi
hanno chiuso in 2 mi hanno chiuso in 2
sono in due potete farmi fuori porco
damon e visita alleati ma che è dai
ragazzi ho fatti seri e sono abbastanza
che possa sopravvivere tutti possono
morire tipo questo mi chiacchie botta
gargamelli che che disastro fatti fuori
66 se solo prendersi tutti tutti che mi
spettano per queste kill borsari ha
rivinto sarei già in classifica ho fatto
una strage no ammazzati tre giganti ed
ero un brano come ho fatto
no vabbè rai4 gaming vero peccato che
non mi arrivano i punti che mi spettano
però 4 gaming vero regalo o fatti fuori
tre in una botta sola
ecco esatto vedere no no mi chiamo
aperto un'altra pagina
no no non mi pagare non mila gare adesso
non mi la gare adesso puoi la gare
quando vuoi ma non adesso per cortesia
foto sono 2007 dai dai dai dai dai dai
pongo mori ecco se rimango in zona gente
muore affidatevi perché facile che si
schiantino tra di loro e poi uno dei
punti quindi devo solo rimanere qua e
perseverare perfetto e cosatto qua per
c'è un sacco di gente che schiatta vedi
devo perseverare su sti punti
praticamente se rischio a perseverare su
sti punti è fantastico perché guadagni
ne guadagna un sacco devo stare solo
attento a non farmi ingolosire dai
troppi punti perché poi ci schiatto come
schiattano tutti questi però è un'ottima
tattica secondo me almeno per diventare
grosso all'inizio sono a 3.000 punti
regala questo vuole tentare di a vorrei
di tentare di chiudermi eyepet sente
schifoso ti ho visto lurido l'aido tempo
assino guarda schifo a c'erano quasi
riuscito io addirittura a chiuderlo che
è molto più grosso di me questo
semplicemente perché ero messo in una
posizione favorevole però pezzente ci ha
provato
non male normale devo calmarmi perché si
sta agitando la situazione se mi agito
con muoio
calma madonna minore che erano piccoli
questi che rischio no no perché si
uniscono tutti per rompermi le palle
perché state a casa levatevi cosa volete
da me ma levatevi tutti che si uniscono
maggiorenne a guarda per rompere le
palle tutti sempre così sempre stato
così niente l'aca proviamo l'ultima
perché è che fastidio è sempre così che
muoio che fastidio muoio sempre perché
qualcuno mi travasa le balle sempre a
salvini superstar
porca vacca salvini superstar
stavo per ammazzare salvini superstar
che sta settimo in classifica e questo
mannaia continua a seguire salvini
superstar di serie la cosa ucciso qua
fratello mio quanti punti e missy mi son
dovuti che però mi ha [ __ ] non c'è
meritocrazia in questo gioco ho fatto
fuori il gigante porca vacca niente dai
ragazzi è stato bello è molto più
difficile di quello che c'è veramente
sto gioco era bellissima bellissimo solo
che madron che casino signori questo era
criteri o dopo 60 anni e non è male è
effettivamente ritornarci però era poi
per riportare quelle vibes che c'erano
in questa bellissima camera prevede sia
piaciuto ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale
schiaccia il tasto mi piace è un
commento su schede visse c'eravate i
tempi quando giocava ma slither io io
personalmente certo non avreste mai
detto e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]